the Joe Rogan experience what do you
think could be versus Dustin looks like
because that's what they're setting up
that's the next fight in Abu Dhabi
I don't know III really don't know I'd
like to say right yeah before the max
fight I would have for sure been like
Abby's gonna blow him out the water he's
gonna take him down he's gonna be too
big but but I just really wasn't trying
to take him down the way could be will
it's a difference it's a different
fighter yeah but but the way does his
footwork was looking at um that's what
makes you think about it because you
know Kobe was kind of a one-track one
want one train my you know he's gonna
come right at you you know he's gonna do
too yeah but if Dustin not even
necessarily can can out wrestle him it's
just it's way easier to play defense on
wrestling and then offense and if you've
got great footwork like that to to keep
a your back off the fence it might be a
long night if it could be who knows the
fights a good fight so fine Dustin's got
that serious power yeah it's a good
Dustin can hurt you yeah zag yep
you know southpaw I think that's gonna
play a big factor in it you know it's a
little harder to get in on a lot of
those shots the real key is can he stop
the takedown and can he defend himself
on the ground because with so many guys
could be gets a hold of them and then
they develop that thousand-yard stare
whether like what in the [ __ ] is
happening you know it's like when I mean
especially I'm sure you remember early
in your career when you would go with a
guy who's just way bigger than you or
way stronger than you and you just go oh
I can't do [ __ ] yeah yeah I can't do
[ __ ] I'm just sort of surviving here
yeah i me i still try and put myself in
those situations not roll with Robert
Drysdale there's something I'm lucky
just to I'm just counting how many times
I rode with Vinny Magalhaes
and I'm like I'm just trying my best not
to get submitted yeah I'm at the point
where now he you only gonna submit me
one or two times you know before it was
like 10 like it was like as many times
as he wanted to but you know like okay
if I slowly pick at this and then I was
so shocked he didn't win that pfl thing
I was so shocked I thought he was gonna
win it for sure yeah yeah his striking
has come so far you know it's one of us
that you know it's the game yeah it's
the game
the game yeah what can you do it's a
[ __ ] crazy sport it really is the
craziest sport that's ever existed
you never know even as an athlete like
you you can do everything to prepare
right and you feel like all the chips
and like everything's in your corner and
like I mean I guess it's like life it's
like you think everything is just right
but sometimes it's not yeah should have
what can you do pick it up and yeah try
it again like a madman well you just
have to accept that this is what you've
chosen you know and this is part of what
comes with it it's just chaos
[Applause]